[SPEAKER_04]: Second and Wealsun, around 3.20pm.
[SPEAKER_04]: Folsum, you're with your unit.
[SPEAKER_04]: You're part of a crossbow unit that is part of the Monmurian fleet.
[SPEAKER_01]: And you and Tyrus have been ordered to report to the Royal Docks for a mission.
[SPEAKER_01]: So you and Tyrus
[SPEAKER_01]: Along with your marine sergeant have traveled from the harbor district down to the royal docks where a COSERA is waiting and you see many, many platoons of marines
[SPEAKER_04]: Collecting there.
[SPEAKER_04]: Tyrus, your entire detachment is collecting at the Royal Docks for some strange mission.
[SPEAKER_01]: Basically you're sitting there, your sergeant is giving orders, and the men are basically arming themselves and moving their equipment onto the boat as are 250 other Marines.
[SPEAKER_01]: So there's something strange going on.
[SPEAKER_01]: Most of the men are asking questions and you hear them talking among themselves.
[SPEAKER_01]: Where are we going?
[SPEAKER_01]: What is this for?
[SPEAKER_01]: Some people are basically saying, I don't know, we're going to reinforce somewhere.
[SPEAKER_01]: Other people are saying that there are assaults that are going to happen.
[SPEAKER_01]: You're not sure of these things.
[SPEAKER_01]: There seems to be a lot of discussion regarding Helm Island and some strange storm that occurred last night.
[SPEAKER_01]: Near the island.
[SPEAKER_01]: Very confusing though.
[SPEAKER_01]: The fact that the royal docks are being used to sally forth from this are doubly strange.
[SPEAKER_01]: However, it becomes a little more obvious when a strange figure walks down from the royal palace on their personal
[SPEAKER_01]: A stairwell.
[SPEAKER_01]: A figure dressed in black clothing, which is strange because it's kind of hot and it seems like that would be very, very suffocating.
[SPEAKER_01]: Wearing a silvered mask over his face.
[SPEAKER_01]: He's accompanied also by a
[SPEAKER_01]: A terse-looking elf, who's wearing a hat, trying to, in some way, disguise the fact that he's elven.
[SPEAKER_01]: But the two of them walk past the marines, causing some kind of a... people to stop and look.
[SPEAKER_01]: It's kind of strange.
[SPEAKER_01]: And then they walk up and get onto the top deck, the steerage deck, with the captain.
[SPEAKER_01]: One of the Marines says, I think that's Paul Ribeiro.
[SPEAKER_01]: I've only heard rumors of him.
[SPEAKER_01]: He's Prince Gian's nephew.
[SPEAKER_04]: Where are we?
[SPEAKER_04]: You guys, you walk up, right, and you actually know these two guys, okay?
[SPEAKER_04]: Merrick is a well-known scout and navigator.
[SPEAKER_01]: In the Monmurgian Navy.
[SPEAKER_01]: He actually is attached directly with Lord Seamus, but you know the sergeants and you know these two guys from whatever.
[SPEAKER_04]: With him is this kind of older-looking, rough-looking guy.
[SPEAKER_04]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_04]: I would say he's not that much older than you guys, maybe.
[SPEAKER_04]: Human though?
[SPEAKER_04]: He's human.
[SPEAKER_04]: He's Iridian.
[SPEAKER_04]: Yeah, definitely.
[SPEAKER_04]: A seagoing man, armed like a Marine, definitely.
[SPEAKER_03]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_03]: Which one was Paul Rivera there?
[SPEAKER_03]: Did they point it out?
[SPEAKER_04]: Paul Rivera is standing on the top deck and they're talking about him.
[SPEAKER_04]: He's got this metal mask, this silvered mask on his face.
[SPEAKER_04]: Kind of like, you know, I'm going to describe it this way.
[SPEAKER_04]: You guys know, have you heard legends of what leopards that were royalty would do?
[SPEAKER_04]: Lepers?
[SPEAKER_04]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: You guys ever hear of the king of Jerusalem?
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: Who was a leper and he had this mask on his face that was just totally silver?
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: Right?
[SPEAKER_01]: He did that because he didn't want to scare people, right?
[SPEAKER_01]: But it's basically what royalty would do during the Middle Ages if they got a horrible disfiguring disease, smallpox or whatever, right?
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: Now, all of you know who Paul Rivero is, even though he's kind of a mysterious person in Lord Jeanne's court.
[SPEAKER_01]: He is the son of Jeanne's sister, Lady Alleria.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: Who died many years ago.
[SPEAKER_01]: And Paul Ribeiro never really shows his face, but the rumor is that he was horribly disfigured when he was a child by some weird accident.
[SPEAKER_04]: And Merrick is with him?
[SPEAKER_04]: Not Merrick.
[SPEAKER_01]: Oh.
[SPEAKER_04]: This weird looking elf, this like kind of tight-lipped,
[SPEAKER_04]: Elf.
[SPEAKER_04]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_04]: Right, with a very, kind of a sour look on his face.
[SPEAKER_00]: It's like, not a joyous elf.
[SPEAKER_00]: Like, should have been born a dark elf, but isn't one.
[SPEAKER_00]: Exactly.
[SPEAKER_03]: And so how do I know these two, just from past adventures?
[SPEAKER_04]: These guys are Marines.
[SPEAKER_04]: And of course, you know Tyrus.
[SPEAKER_04]: Tyrus is actually well known in the fleet.
[SPEAKER_04]: He's kind of a boisterous guy.
[SPEAKER_04]: Very charismatic.
[SPEAKER_04]: Everybody loves him.
[SPEAKER_04]: Tyrus?
[SPEAKER_04]: Tyrus, yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: He's a big dude.
[SPEAKER_04]: He's a big dude.
[SPEAKER_01]: And Folsom is actually their companions because there's nothing that Tyrus likes more than to listen to Folsom play as Five because he's the best musician in the fleet, basically.
[SPEAKER_01]: Not a very good fighter, but
[SPEAKER_01]: Having somebody that lifts morale on a ship is probably more important most of the time anyway, so that's definitely what the deal is.
[SPEAKER_04]: Anyway, as the two of you walk up, Tyrus' unit is the one that you're going to be attached to.
[SPEAKER_01]: The two of you see Merrick coming towards you, you know he knows something.
[SPEAKER_01]: He always does.
[SPEAKER_00]: And I'm with him.
[SPEAKER_00]: He's with him.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_02]: And so this guy is a little suspicious to both of you.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_02]: And Merrick, is it human?
[SPEAKER_02]: Merrick's Aridean.
[SPEAKER_02]: You're all Arideans.
[SPEAKER_02]: All of us.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_03]: Aristotle.
[SPEAKER_03]: So they walk up to us?
[SPEAKER_03]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_03]: Tyrus, good to see you.
[SPEAKER_03]: Merrick, bye!
[SPEAKER_03]: My colleague Aristotle's good to meet ya.
[SPEAKER_00]: Nice to meet you.
[SPEAKER_00]: It's a pleasure, Aristotle.
[SPEAKER_00]: Names Folsom.
[SPEAKER_00]: Folsom.
[SPEAKER_00]: Can you play that thing?
[SPEAKER_00]: And I play it well.
[SPEAKER_00]: Dwell.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: Play Dwell.
[SPEAKER_03]: Merrick, good to see you.
[SPEAKER_03]: Folsum, what instruments are you bringing on this little trip we're going on?
[SPEAKER_03]: Oh, nothing crazy.
[SPEAKER_03]: Just as usual.
[SPEAKER_03]: Great.
[SPEAKER_03]: My favorite.
[SPEAKER_00]: I know you love it.
[SPEAKER_00]: I'm playing the crossbow.
[SPEAKER_00]: As usual.
[SPEAKER_00]: A popular one amongst us.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_00]: The sergeant walks up.
[SPEAKER_00]: He's got a certain twang.
[SPEAKER_04]: And he says,
[SPEAKER_04]: Merrick, you joined us.
[SPEAKER_04]: Jameis said you'd be here.
[SPEAKER_04]: I got a message from him.
[SPEAKER_04]: Can I inquire as to why you're coming with us?
[SPEAKER_03]: Jameis' orders.
[SPEAKER_03]: Heard the weather was a little rough lately, so he needed me to, you know, steer the ship or watch out for anything that we might find alarming.
[SPEAKER_03]: Do you know why we're going to Helm Island?
[SPEAKER_03]: Not in particular.
[SPEAKER_03]: Am I supposed to share this with him?
[SPEAKER_03]: No, no idea why we're going to Helm Island.
[SPEAKER_03]: I heard that we maybe need to be checking on a shitlip coming in, patrolling some goods.
[SPEAKER_03]: So this is a supply run?
[SPEAKER_04]: We're supplying Helm Island?
[SPEAKER_03]: No, making sure other supply runs get there safely.
[SPEAKER_03]: It's an escort trip.
[SPEAKER_03]: Essentially, yes.
[SPEAKER_03]: Who's this?
[SPEAKER_03]: Aristotle's.
[SPEAKER_01]: He kind of looks you up in the middle.
[SPEAKER_01]: Do a performance roll, which is a 20.
[SPEAKER_00]: One die 20.
[SPEAKER_00]: What am I looking for?
[SPEAKER_01]: I don't know.
[SPEAKER_04]: Well, there's a DC associated with it.
[SPEAKER_04]: What's your performance?
[SPEAKER_00]: Performance is a minus one.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay, so you're trying to pass.
[SPEAKER_00]: So, roll.
[SPEAKER_00]: Nine.
[SPEAKER_04]: Minus one is eight, which is my charisma.
[SPEAKER_04]: He kind of looks at you up and down.
[SPEAKER_04]: And what do you want to, do you want to say anything?
[SPEAKER_00]: Weathered crossbowman.
[SPEAKER_00]: Just assigned here.
[SPEAKER_00]: I see.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_00]: I shoot well in bad weather.
[SPEAKER_03]: Great for hunting off the side of the ship.
[SPEAKER_04]: Well, I'm wondering why we need your abilities now.
[SPEAKER_04]: However, since Merrick won't tell us what is going on, I guess we'll need to get on the ship.
[SPEAKER_04]: Sounds good to me.
[SPEAKER_00]: Folsum.
[SPEAKER_00]: Give us a marching tune so we can get the men on board.
[SPEAKER_00]: Let's load up, as you say.
[SPEAKER_00]: Start playing this badass tune.
[SPEAKER_00]: Let's move it, fellas.
[SPEAKER_01]: He says to you, loud enough for Gouge to hear, Aristotle to hear.
[SPEAKER_01]: Keep your eye on that one.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yes, sir.
[SPEAKER_00]: Notice I switched to regular padded leather and a crossbow.
[SPEAKER_00]: An old school one, yes.
[SPEAKER_04]: There you go.
[SPEAKER_04]: Okay, so to the tune of the five, Folsom's five, the unit marches up the gangplank.
[SPEAKER_04]: Thirty men, ten crossbow men, marines, and twenty normal marines.
[SPEAKER_04]: And you.
[SPEAKER_04]: Okay?
[SPEAKER_04]: So, you guys are part of the unit.
[SPEAKER_04]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_04]: You're part of the crossbow unit.
[SPEAKER_04]: 20 marines.
[SPEAKER_04]: 20 marines, 10 marines with crossbow marines.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_04]: The crossbow marines wear studded leather and do not have shields, but have light crossbows.
[SPEAKER_04]: The normal marines wear scale mail, like you.
[SPEAKER_04]: They have shields and they have long swords.
[SPEAKER_04]: Crossbow marines have short swords, but they don't really want to get into hand-to-hand combat.
[SPEAKER_04]: That's not something they're into.
[SPEAKER_02]: And then, plus us.
[SPEAKER_04]: You are part of the 20.
[SPEAKER_04]: You're one of the 20.
[SPEAKER_04]: The sergeant counts as different.
[SPEAKER_01]: So really, all in all, there are 32 men in the unit that you're in.
[SPEAKER_01]: He's an odd man out.
[SPEAKER_01]: He's a scout slash navigator.
[SPEAKER_01]: The sergeant's the sergeant.
[SPEAKER_01]: I'm one of the 10 crossbow men.
[SPEAKER_01]: You're one of the 10 crossbow men.
[SPEAKER_00]: You're one of the 10 crossbow men.
[SPEAKER_00]: You're one of the Marines.
[SPEAKER_00]: Was I allowed to bring my actual weapons or no?
[SPEAKER_00]: Oh yeah.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: So it's just my armor that swapped out.
[SPEAKER_00]: Heavy crossbow or am I using a light to match?
[SPEAKER_00]: No, you have a heavy crossbow.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: Which does stand out.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_00]: You have quite the artillery there.
[SPEAKER_02]: All right.
[SPEAKER_02]: So we're loading up.
[SPEAKER_02]: Did I get everybody moving?
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: Get everybody on that ship for me.
[SPEAKER_02]: That's my job.
[SPEAKER_00]: No talking in the ranks.
[SPEAKER_04]: Let's go.
[SPEAKER_04]: Let's move along, people.
[SPEAKER_04]: So you guys walk up the gangplank and get on the boat, joining the other 250 marines that are on board and actually on deck.
[SPEAKER_01]: And this is starting to feel a little more like an invasion force than anything else.
[SPEAKER_04]: It's not a huge group of guys.
[SPEAKER_04]: It's really obvious.
[SPEAKER_04]: Not an escort group.
[SPEAKER_04]: It's not like people are breaking down their weapons and going below deck for a long voyage.
[SPEAKER_00]: What is the length of voyage?
[SPEAKER_01]: We would know this.
[SPEAKER_01]: Hellen Island is maybe five, six miles out from Monmurg.
[SPEAKER_01]: It's right there.
[SPEAKER_01]: It's probably going to take an hour or two.
[SPEAKER_01]: Great.
[SPEAKER_01]: Depending on what the weather is like.
[SPEAKER_01]: I mean, it's a very short jaunt.
[SPEAKER_01]: You can see it right there.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_04]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_04]: What's the weather like?
[SPEAKER_04]: It's a clear day.
[SPEAKER_04]: And actually, light breeze, perfect sailing weather.
[SPEAKER_04]: Have I ever been there at all?
[SPEAKER_04]: You've been to Helm Island, yeah.
[SPEAKER_04]: You've actually done...
[SPEAKER_01]: Your garrison duty there when the Lord Jameis was in control of the helm.
[SPEAKER_01]: You've never been in the helm itself, which is the fortification on the top of the hill.
[SPEAKER_04]: But you've been in the barracks, and you know the lighthouses and the roads.
[SPEAKER_04]: So if you want to see the basic layout of the helm, it looks like that.
[SPEAKER_00]: Our goal is to the docks, I'm assuming.
[SPEAKER_04]: Yeah, so basically the
[SPEAKER_04]: Lighthouses there, there, and there.
[SPEAKER_01]: Aid for navigation.
[SPEAKER_01]: These two are different colors.
[SPEAKER_01]: One's red, one's blue.
[SPEAKER_01]: And basically they tell you if you are on the western side of Helm Island and approaching the docks of Monmurg, there's another lighthouse over in Monmurg, that you can use it to say, hey, I'm on the right course.
[SPEAKER_01]: Or if you're going too far east and you're heading towards the Flotsam Island.
[SPEAKER_02]: And it would be sitting
[SPEAKER_02]: Like this, coming from Monmurg this direction.
[SPEAKER_02]: Well, Monmurg is over here.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay, coming from over here.
[SPEAKER_02]: So we would have to sail around this side or around that side to get to the dock.
[SPEAKER_04]: Exactly.
[SPEAKER_04]: The southern beacon is basically saying you're approaching from behind.
[SPEAKER_04]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_04]: And normally what you do is you go towards Monmurg and go that way.
[SPEAKER_04]: But you can still figure out whether you're on the western side or eastern side.
[SPEAKER_04]: And there is a small dock on this side then?
[SPEAKER_04]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_04]: The southern beacon has a small set of docks there also.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: But we're heading for the main docks I assume.
[SPEAKER_00]: Not me.
[SPEAKER_04]: The captain is not telling you anything.
[SPEAKER_02]: In this ship, is it an obvious warship?
[SPEAKER_02]: It's got cannons?
[SPEAKER_04]: No cannons.
[SPEAKER_04]: There's no such thing as cannons.
[SPEAKER_04]: But it has ballista.
[SPEAKER_04]: It has four ballista on it.
[SPEAKER_01]: And it is basically a standard coasterer, which are really fast ships.
[SPEAKER_01]: And what they're designed to do is to close with other ships.
[SPEAKER_01]: And usually larger ships and board.
[SPEAKER_01]: That's kind of how the Monmurgans fight their battles.
[SPEAKER_01]: They don't like to use catapults or anything like that.
[SPEAKER_01]: And usually what will happen is two or three Corsairs will track down a ship, a lone ship, cut him off from his friends, and then board him and kill everybody on board.
[SPEAKER_01]: That's the way they act.
[SPEAKER_01]: And they use speed to be able to do that.
[SPEAKER_01]: They wait for them.
[SPEAKER_01]: It's like wolves.
[SPEAKER_04]: Killing lions is what they do.
[SPEAKER_01]: Keog ships are usually larger, the Keog Manor Wars are usually larger, with more marines, but they're slow, like half as fast.
[SPEAKER_01]: So they'll never catch a Cosaire, because Cosaires will usually lead them into dangerous walkers.
[SPEAKER_01]: Either wreck them or, you know, overwhelm them.
[SPEAKER_04]: Anyway, so you guys leave the docks around, I would say, 4 p.m., 3.30 p.m., and begin sailing towards Helmshaw.
[SPEAKER_03]: Do we know where Paul Ribeiro is located?
[SPEAKER_01]: He's on the main deck with the captain and he and the elf basically are in conversations with the captain through the
[SPEAKER_01]: The Voyage.
[SPEAKER_01]: Do you want to keep your eye on them and kind of see what they're doing or do you want to stay innocuous?
[SPEAKER_03]: I do want to stand back on the helm near them in earshot but also act like I'm patrolling the weather and watching for the sea.
[SPEAKER_04]: Okay, so you want to actually use, this is something where you use your perception to try to intercept what they're saying.
[SPEAKER_01]: Do you want to do that?
[SPEAKER_04]: Yeah, let's do it.
[SPEAKER_01]: Merrick has a little more leeway than the rank and file of the troops because he's not really a part of any unit and doesn't have to stand with his group.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, being a scout, he wouldn't.
[SPEAKER_00]: He's gonna walk around and do his thing.
[SPEAKER_00]: He's not gonna be bullshitting like us with the others.
[SPEAKER_00]: Right.
[SPEAKER_04]: So what do you, wait, is there a question?
[SPEAKER_00]: Do I recognize the elf?
[SPEAKER_00]: I'll keep my distance.
[SPEAKER_02]: Any of this typically...
[SPEAKER_02]: Could land at anywhere on here, or is it pretty much the docks are the only place you can go?
[SPEAKER_04]: Well, no, no, no.
[SPEAKER_04]: I mean, you could take a long boat and go up to that, but you wouldn't want to get the ship close.
[SPEAKER_00]: Right, right.
[SPEAKER_00]: Appreciate it.
[SPEAKER_00]: Don't want to mess up your plane skills.
[SPEAKER_02]: And there's no other landing boats on this or anything else, I mean, other than your basic...
[SPEAKER_02]: What do you mean?
[SPEAKER_02]: There's no other smaller ships on this here that would... Oh no, there are long boats on this ship.
[SPEAKER_02]: Oh, there are.
[SPEAKER_04]: This ship has two long boats.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_02]: For landing.
[SPEAKER_00]: But just two, that wouldn't be enough.
[SPEAKER_00]: Took a snort offered to him, he refused, but...
[SPEAKER_00]: Took a...
[SPEAKER_00]: So Aristotle is drinking in the ranks.
[SPEAKER_00]: Not blatantly in front of everyone.
[SPEAKER_02]: Just a little nipper.
[SPEAKER_02]: I'm glad you always have that on you.
[SPEAKER_03]: I do.
[SPEAKER_03]: Am I going to roll for perception?
[SPEAKER_04]: You keep your ear out.
[SPEAKER_04]: Do roll for perception, actually.
[SPEAKER_04]: And what is your perception bonus?
[SPEAKER_03]: Plus six.
[SPEAKER_03]: Nice.
[SPEAKER_03]: I'm going to say that this is a DC-10 role
[SPEAKER_04]: You're going to be kind of walking around back and forth near the deck to try and hear what they're saying.
[SPEAKER_01]: So you have to roll a four or better to kind of get what's going on.
[SPEAKER_01]: Four or better?
[SPEAKER_04]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_04]: So it's going to be a roll plus your six.
[SPEAKER_04]: So it's DC 10, which means you have to roll at least a 10, but you have a perception of six.
[SPEAKER_04]: So that's what it is.
[SPEAKER_00]: So four or better?
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_00]: On a 10 side.
[SPEAKER_00]: 20.
[SPEAKER_00]: Oh, on a 20?
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_00]: Oh, DC 10 on though.
[SPEAKER_00]: That's okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: Not here.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: Fourteen.
[SPEAKER_01]: So, as you travel, and the trip is going to take about an hour and a half, you hear... What magic is that?
[SPEAKER_01]: You hear...
[SPEAKER_01]: This elf, for some reason, talking to the captain.
[SPEAKER_01]: Should we not listen to this?
[SPEAKER_01]: About, it's okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: I mean, if it's something like he's going to stab you in the back, I won't, but I assume he's going to say something to you at some point.
[SPEAKER_01]: Talking to the captain about being prepared.
[SPEAKER_01]: And you get the feeling that the elf knows something more than what the captain knows because the captain actually questions him a few times about what is going on.
[SPEAKER_01]: This is just a, I'm just going there to make sure that everything's fine.
[SPEAKER_01]: And the elf is like, yeah, but you may want to have this prepared.
[SPEAKER_01]: You may want to do this.
[SPEAKER_01]: Basically talking about being cautious and
[SPEAKER_01]: You can tell that the elf is trying to get Paul Rivero to back him up.
[SPEAKER_01]: So there seems to be some kind of a weird sort of power dynamic going on there.
[SPEAKER_01]: The captain's not really 100% sure what to do, because even though Paul Rivero is kind of backing the elf up and saying, just do what he says, it's like you can tell that the captain is really worried.
[SPEAKER_01]: This gets actually
[SPEAKER_01]: More problematic as you guys are approaching the Southern Beacon.
[SPEAKER_01]: When you're about a quarter mile off the Southern Beacon, the elf says basically, I think you should approach the docks safely.
[SPEAKER_01]: And he should be worried about that lighthouse.
[SPEAKER_01]: And he points to the southern lighthouse.
[SPEAKER_01]: And the captain says, why?
[SPEAKER_01]: I see no problems there.
[SPEAKER_01]: The elf basically says, yeah, but you haven't gotten a signal from them yet, so you don't know what's happening there.
[SPEAKER_01]: At that point, the captain
[SPEAKER_04]: Looks very kind of mad and concerned, and he looks down and says, Sergeant, first and second squads, in the longboats, I want you to go up to the garrison on the southern beacon, check the docks.
[SPEAKER_01]: Your sergeant basically says, Tyrus, get the men ready.
[SPEAKER_04]: Everybody goes and the units grab the longboats and start carrying them over to the side of the boat.
[SPEAKER_01]: The port side of the boat?
[SPEAKER_01]: You're going up the left side, it's the port side of the boat, yes.
[SPEAKER_01]: And this boat turns this way.
[SPEAKER_01]: To go around that way, but you guys are going to be let off about an eighth of a mile from the shore.
[SPEAKER_01]: That appears to be what the captain wants.
[SPEAKER_01]: Your sergeant goes up and the captain has some words with him.
[SPEAKER_04]: Right.
[SPEAKER_04]: And then he comes back and says, all right, we're to be dropped off here.
[SPEAKER_04]: We're going to secure the barracks of the Southern Beacon.
[SPEAKER_02]: These are the barracks, then?
[SPEAKER_02]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_02]: So we've got to cross this whole area here.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_00]: So anyway, who picks the... How many of us are going?
[SPEAKER_00]: Your entire unit.
[SPEAKER_00]: Get wrenched.
[SPEAKER_00]: There's 20 of us.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: 30 of you.
[SPEAKER_00]: 30 of us.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_03]: 32, actually.
[SPEAKER_03]: Are I going with, as well?
[SPEAKER_03]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_03]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_03]: Do you ask that question?
[SPEAKER_03]: Yeah, I do ask that question.
[SPEAKER_04]: The sergeant says, Merrick, he wants you to come with us.
[SPEAKER_04]: The captain wants your eyes.
[SPEAKER_03]: Who's going to be left with the captain and our two esteemed guests?
[SPEAKER_03]: They'll be protected.
[SPEAKER_04]: He's worried about
[SPEAKER_04]: What's here?
[SPEAKER_01]: We'll signal him once we get to the barracks.
[SPEAKER_01]: Give him the all clear.
[SPEAKER_01]: We need your eyes on this.
[SPEAKER_01]: We want to make sure the bay is good.
[SPEAKER_01]: Understood.
[SPEAKER_01]: Grab an oar, boys.
[SPEAKER_04]: All right.
[SPEAKER_04]: So you guys get in the longboats and they lower down the first longboat and 15 of the men claim rent.
[SPEAKER_04]: 16 of the men claim rent.
[SPEAKER_04]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_04]: And push away.
[SPEAKER_04]: Roll dice.
[SPEAKER_04]: Roll six-sided dice.
[SPEAKER_04]: Each of you roll a six-sided dice.
[SPEAKER_04]: If it's even, you're in the first one.
[SPEAKER_04]: If it's odd, you're in the second one.
[SPEAKER_00]: I'm on.
[SPEAKER_00]: You're all in the second one.
[SPEAKER_00]: Except for... We'll see.
[SPEAKER_02]: All right, so we have this moment here so you guys know, a physical look of me.
[SPEAKER_02]: I'm six foot four, like 240.